oh I don't know mister why do you think
that this little work I can't sit out
right this will really work try it this
will really work this will will I can't
say it I can't do it
I don't know mister why do you think
[Music]
you're doesn't loser who can never
afford to eat at Tara's ah no see you
made it you're pathetic life's little
mission to destroy the people who can
just a police dog right there
it was weird after but then it was okay
dog died later AIDS sorry
[Laughter]
I think he's stable enough now for you
to go and see him briefly I'm sorry but
I think it's it's immediate family only
we're all family I understand but it was
a certain protocol I know baby hmm if
this weren't Tara's ADO's I would beat
you to death
[Applause]
have you heard of Blacula the black
dracula yes
well they had a Jewish Dracula Oh what
isn't it Sidney Applebaum
[Applause]
he's smoking me let him leave the nest
[Music]
[Applause]
grizzly bear is a bear this is still
safe right
I know luck sure I'm a fan of this bit
okay dad me here because I'm fart gnomes
money okay and you're lucky to have me
here cuz I'm far it numbs money [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm so sorry I'm kicking your ass
and Pizza fight really wish you would
not do that really I really wish I would
do it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
okay I get your point sir I don't enjoy
obscenities as much as you but those
words are not illegal well the First
Amendment says that they're not if you
say screw you one more time whoa okay
guys also it's bad for the environment
and it's dress computer company do you
know what it takes to compete IBM
Microsoft yes I do
and that's why I've got a secret weapon
my son no no no like this
hey can I ask you something that I've
always want to ask real Batman yeah
are you as strong as mine my friend
Dominik day astronomer damn how is
Dominic he's good I don't mean this in
any bad way but have you ever made out
with another woman why because for my
analysis I think you'd love it
can I ask you something I was the one
that has the real Batman yeah since
you're a big bet can you turn into a
tiny vampire anytime anyplace do no
don't do now we'll do it later
I want to figure out I tried to do some
research once Mohs and I rented a movie
about a Latino wedding planner with a
big fan and now I throw his hair into a
tiny little fire wasn't stranded it's
hard
the pace can I ask you something I
always want to ask the real Batman yeah
are you my uncle Troy are we gonna kiss
oh my god just an Cola okay oh my god
that you've done this before no I have
it's just it's no picnic
everything asbestos lupus the magazines
at Supercuts i do not already had one
and I didn't like it can I can I ask you
something I always want to ask the real
Batman yeah
Wow your move is so good don't it's not
funny it's a legit question Holland is
the Netherlands
you know each chicken looks as good as
anyone that's the chicken man guarantee
[Applause]
seems nice to pet though
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Walter you're never gonna see him again
yeah that's what you think I'm gonna get
a gun when we go to his house and shoot
him in the head
Hey Hey how do my whole your what can I
talk to you for a second showing up
what's up sugar
I think I found most of the pieces you
single-handed but stands and Sun on the
brink of bankruptcy oh I have an idea
what about his penis should I talk to
her yeah I should talk to him about
something he's interested in right like
his penis can't be brainy my turn here
no I know nothing about wedding planning
I tried to do some research once Mose
and I rented a movie about a Latino
wedding planner with enormous the bar
I'm getting that nothing except for my
baby carrots
she's going away a long long time